on November 20th 2022 news spoke that
actor and martial artist Jason David
Frank died at 49 years old while Frank's
acting career spanned decades his best
known work was playing the green and
white Rangers in the original Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers TV series news of
Frank's death hit fans hard given the
important party played in the
franchise's early popularity and
subsequent development Frank's life even
mirrored that of the Green Ranger in
that both he and his most well-known
character ended up succeeding in
unlikely ways in Power Rangers Canon the
Green Ranger starts off as a villain
before overcoming his evil influence and
eventually leading the Power Rangers
team Frank meanwhile initially signed on
for just 10 episodes of Power Rangers
But ultimately became so popular he
stuck around not just for the balance of
the original Power Rangers show but for
a number of subsequent incarnations of
Power Rangers also of course Frank
booked the Green Ranger role in the
first place at least partially on the
strength of his martial arts abilities
in fact Frank's martial arts expertise
nearly landed him in a fight with noted
movie star Jean-Claude Van Damme on two
separate occasions I don't want to hurt
you
in November 2017 Combat Sports Blog flow
combat published a history of the
contentious relationship between Frank
and Van Damme including some direct
quotes from Frank himself explaining how
they're Dynamic twice nearly erupted
into full-on fights first Frank met
VanDam who he had idolized at a Power
Rangers event in 1995 Frank found Van
Damme rude and in 2010 issued a
challenge to fight Van Damme in an
organized mixed martial arts match this
first possible fight however never came
to fruition then backstage at a
Comic-Con event in 2017 after both
actors finished scheduled appearances
Van Damme approached Frank alongside his
Entourage seemingly looking to provoke
the Green Ranger into hitting him Frank
told flow combat I clinched up with him
and put him against the wall and he's
talking and he froze up and I raised my
knee and said do you want to do this and
he doesn't do anything so I let go
shortly after that Comic-Con security
separated the two men a daily mail piece
about this incident notes that Frank
also challenged Herschel Walker and pro
wrestlers CM Punk to fight him as well
whereas nothing came of these challenges
however his beef with Van Damme
culminated in a Face-Off seven years
later that nearly blew up into a
backstage brawl according to Frank's
account the aggressor in the situation
was Van Damme Frank meanwhile had
previously suggested the two compete in
a sanctioned MMA competition despite the
nature of this experience Frank
maintained that he held no ill will
toward Van Damme in its aftermath in a
Facebook post shortly after news of the
incident broke for example Frank
encouraged fans of Van Damme's films to
continue to appreciate his body of work
without letting the near fight influence
their opinion Frank also discussed their
combative history during a q a at a 2021
Comic-Con event a fan asked Frank if
he's still interested in an organized
bout with Van Damme Frank responded that
while his game his only interest in the
fight would be to raise money for
charity given that he holds no ill will
toward Van Damme personally while
Frank's disappointment with Van Damme as
an individual dated back to 1995 the
Power Rangers star was adamant about
separating the artist from his art in
his final years